like when you play have you ever played
metal gear uh
no okay none of them uh no because i it
was like
i don't know why but like i never really
saw it in like the shops
probably because it was also on
playstation as well right i had
playstation 2 growing up
right but yeah for some reason i was
probably playing like shrek and spyro
and damn [ __ ] like that
good choice i was really like yeah when
i was uh when i was younger i wasn't
attracted at all to like the
fps art or like the like military
looking stuff
right i always went for the childish
cartoonish
yeah yeah yeah even when i was like 14
15 i would still like to prefer the
cartoon anime style over
yeah so i i normally avoided those so i
was playing like [ __ ] theme park
games and [ __ ] when i was like 15.
rollercoaster tycooning
well playstation had its like uh its own
brand of like these theme park games
yeah and i think they're still quite
popular on youtube occasionally
and you could like you could build the
rides and ride them from
like pov first person oh wow it was
really cool [ __ ]
do you know what i'm on about no no i i
i'm just getting a flashback of memories
now
maybe i should have put that on there
because i've spent far too much time on
theme park or
yeah theme park and theme hospital yeah
yeah i think you know roller coaster
tycoon is
like [ __ ] happened live oh dude i put
way too much honestly it could be
yeah yeah i'm just like [ __ ] man maybe i
should have put that on my list but uh
yeah in terms of like i never got got
into the rollercoaster tycoon because
uh theme park had like the voiced person
telling you what to do
and i don't know something about having
someone voiced telling you what to do
was was a big selling point for me was
that the one the playstation 2 that i'm
on about
maybe i don't know i don't know i don't
know about the box yeah
yeah but but it definitely had a pov
option where you could build the rides
and then
yeah because you could ride it yeah you
could and there's like racing games in
it so when you built like the racing
track you built the track yourself and
you could race around it oh that sounds
cool
yeah dude it was awesome why am i never
heard of this and then like
you could [ __ ] i want to play it now
there was like
there was like the the normal park there
was like an alien park
yeah you remember this and they and each
each world had like
different ride things that you could
ride and like you you couldn't progress
to the next world unless your theme park
was x successful
that just sounds like rollercoaster
tycoon it is like tycoon but like better
because like rollercoaster tycoon is
pure like top down yeah it's just like
you get in there you can walk around
your path
yeah yeah yeah like it was so good why
haven't i never heard of this is the box
art i'm gonna find it
i know what the box art looks like i
think they released other types of games
as well but this is the one that like i
literally
played to death in the ps2 no you you
are reminding me now and i'm just like
[ __ ] i didn't play on ps2 i played it on
pc
it was on pc as well yeah yeah yeah i
was on pc um [ __ ] man
memories nostalgia no because i i
[ __ ] loved simulator games like that
i can i could never get to the sims but
i [ __ ] love
like sim city theme hospital um
roller coaster tycoon not very close to
tycoon uh theme park as you said yeah
god i put so many i just hit him with
that nostalgia
so that's why i like i never really
played military games because i would
always see like the like the bright
light boxes and i think i'm like you
know being a [ __ ] 14 15 year old
you're like
no i was exactly the same when like uh
when like heavy rain came
out yeah yeah and i looked at the ball
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that yeah
and now i regret not playing it back in
the day because much many years later i
played i was like this game's [ __ ]
fantastic because like i loved like
crash bandicoot
so much on the ps2 yeah and like that
was the kind of art style that i
normally gravitated towards so wow
right right like there's so many games
you've like yeah even all the spin-offs
to crash bandicoot yeah like crash
racing
uh they had like the mario party s kind
of game called like crash bash which i
really liked as well
even though it's a terrible game right
now but i used to play it a bunch and
then crash one two and
you know crash racing dude crash racing
racing oh my god
the only racing game that could legit
compete against mario kart
no no no no no uh what was the uh
did he congratulations diddy kong racing
the n64 version because that was when it
could actually compete with
well it was made by rare right yeah you
know i could see
i remember like 10 year old me going to
my friend's place and he had diddy kong
racing on near 64. and i'm like
wait you can ride on airplanes yeah and
like boats what the [ __ ]
yeah like for me i was really close to
putting banjo-kazooie on
what can i say